most of us grew up learning that the
American Constitution our Constitution
guarantees birthright citizenship in
other words anybody born in this country
even to parents who are here illegally
or simply on vacation he's a US citizen
and do all the benefits of that for life
but is that really what the Constitution
says
Michael Anton does not believe it says
that he's a lecturer at Hillsdale
College and a former Trump advisor just
wrote a piece in The Washington Post
arguing that birthright citizenship is
not a constitutional requirement
Michael Anton joins us tonight Michael
thanks all for coming on I'm amazed
there post printed this piece good for
them you took a lot of heat for it
people were shocked by the idea that you
would even question this but you made
your case partly on legal grounds why
does the Constitution not say what we've
been taught it says well you have to
read the whole 14th amendment it says
there's a clause in the middle that
people ignore or they misinterpret
subject to the jurisdiction thereof
they're off meaning of the United States
what they're saying is if you're born on
US soil subject to the jurisdiction of
the United States meaning you're the
child of citizens or the child of legal
immigrants then you are entitled to
citizenship if you're here illegally if
you owe allegiance to a foreign nation
if you're the citizen of a foreign
country that Clause does not apply to
you if you read the debate about the
ratification of the 14th amendment all
the Senators who are discussing what
this is meant to do and what it means
are very clear on this point I tried to
point that out I expected the left would
blow up and get angry which they did
what I didn't expect at least not to
this extent and what was very
disappointing was how angry the
so-called conservative intellectuals got
with me and they essentially said any
opposition to birthright citizenship is
is racist and evil and unamerican and
you know I'm still in the middle of this
debate writing back and forth it'll go
on for a while I'm happy to do it I'm a
happy warrior on these questions but it
shows you you know you asked the speaker
why are the Republicans so bad on this
question he gave you some answers I
asked a parallel question why are the
so-called conservatives the
intellectuals of the conservative
scholars so bad on this question that's
one of the things I'm treating but the
the the nonprofit people who've been
consuming billions of donations or 40
years as the country gets more liberal
and then lecture people like you that
you're sort of not till running their
line it's a deeply unimpressive deeply
unimpressive group I'm Tony to go to if
I were you know I know Chuck you know
I'm talking about the think tank
scholars oh I'm very aware of exactly
you're talking but but let me ask you
this so the people who wrote the 14th
amendment did not envision a moment
where I don't know thousands of Chinese
would fly to Saipan have their children
there so they could become US citizens
or people would sneak in illegally into
this country so their kids would get
American benefits that wasn't kind of a
consideration for the the the purpose of
the 14th amendment was to settle the
question of the citizenship of freed
black slaves so this is right after the
Civil War and you have some people in
the country citing the Dred Scott
decision widely regarded as the worst
Supreme Court decision ever which held
that no black person could ever be a
citizen and the Congress said we're
gonna overturn that forever and make it
clear that if you were born here and
you're subject to the jurisdiction as
all freed slaves were then you are a
citizen and no state can take that away
from you but they also make it clear in
language in the debates and in the Civil
Rights Act of 1866 passed for the same
years this debate by the same Congress
yeah you have to be not subject to any
foreign power in order to be eligible
for birthright citizenship and all the
people attacking me and freaking out
about this they don't really have an
answer to that they just glide past it
and try to obfuscate and point to other
other things that aren't relevant if you
read the debate it's very clear what the
framers of that amendment meant well
because for them as theology it's it's
not a policy debate and you violated a
tenet of their religion and I hope
you'll continue to do that
Pharaoh Elias you have Michael thank you